[Music]
[Music]
i get lots of comments and questions see
if game of thrones prequel series is
cancelled people say they are reading
about it all over the internet the
answer is yes one game of thrones
prequel is cancelled its name was the
long knight or the blood moon but the
other game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon about which i've
been talking about on this channel is
not the game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon is in the process of
filming and will be released early on in
2022 or in other words in just over one
year
unlike the long night prequel hbo
ordered the entire first season of house
of the dragon meaning that this prequel
cannot be cancelled hbo's prequel blood
moon was meant to fill the gap that game
of thrones left behind but a project has
been cancelled and replaced with house
of the dragon if the long night prequel
was not cancelled it would already be
out as 2020 was its official release
date
blood moon was supposed to be about the
long night at first it seemed as if
everything was going just fine with it
and hbo even filmed the pilot but for
whatever reason chose not to turn it
into a series
a pilot episode was written and produced
by jane goldman said thousands of years
before game of thrones hours after
announcing that the blood moon prequel
was cancelled hbo announced that they
ordered the entire first season of house
of the dragon
pilots sometimes they come together
sometimes they don't hbo's president
casey blois told variety about why the
network decided to go with one prequel
series over the other and i would say
that was very much the case here there's
nothing i would point to and say oh this
was the problem however bloise did
reveal that since house of the dragon is
based on martin's writing it was easier
for the show's creative team to delve
into the story of house targaryen that
prequel was 8 000 years before the
current show so it required a lot more
invention he explained one of the
benefits of house of the dragon is there
was a text from george and there was a
little bit more of a roadmap
set more than 5000 years before game of
thrones the cancelled show blood moon
was not planning to feature any of the
game of thrones characters we already
know and love as a matter of fact some
of the houses and families did not even
exist in this time period like
targaryens for example
according to hbo's official synopsis the
blood moon was meant to tell the story
of the world's descent from the golden
age of heroes into its darkest hour
it planned to center around the children
of the forest and how they created the
first white walker we now know as the
night king a teaser for the series said
it will reveal the horrifying secrets of
westeros history to the true origin of
the white walkers the age of heroes is
the name given to the period in time
which saw the first men and the children
of the forest come together to agree on
a piece pact this happened around 10 000
years before the first game of thrones
episode is set it ended around 7 000
years later with the coming of the
andals the exact time the age of heroes
ended is not clear as different sources
in westeros gave different accounts
this meant that the fans would not know
for sure when the blood moon was set the
only details confirmed were that it's
the age of hero zera casey blow is the
president of hbo programming told
deadline one of the things i think jane
took on beautifully which was a
challenge there was a lot more world
creation because she set hers 8 000
years before the original show so it
required a lot more he added we would
have been very lucky to do one pilot
have that pilot go and be a success but
in development as you know it takes a
lot of tries to get it right this is no
different in an interview with
entertainment weekly the creator george
r martin stated that blood moon prequel
was supposed to be set roughly 5 000
years before the events of the game of
thrones we are dealing with a different
and older world martin told the
entertainment weekly in the interview
georgia or martin also said westeros is
a very different place king's landing
will not even exist yet and as a result
there is no iron throne either meanwhile
valyria will have hardly begun to rise
martin explained it's not the story we
think we know it will teach us more
about westeros history the white
walker's origins and the mysteries of
the east in his interview with the new
york times martin stressed that the long
night prequel was mostly the creation of
jane goldman in his own words if you
look at the published books so far
there's really very little material
about the age of heroes and the long
night a sentence here a sentence there
old nan tells a tale that takes up a
paragraph so jane had to create the
characters the settings and some of the
events and we had to look at everything
that was said and say okay here's what
was said at this point we need to make
it consistent to that we kicked around
some ideas and i made some suggestions
but mostly it's been jane running with
it martin therefore explained that he
did not create the plot outline
characters or setting details for the
long night tv series it was announced by
hbo on october 29th 2019 that plans to
produce the long night spin-off had been
scrapped after viewing the pilot hbo was
not thrilled by the results and even
gave showrunner jane goldman and her
team notes on change as needed but even
after the re-edit of the pilot hbo was
still not thrilled and decided not to
green light the pilot to series hours
after the cancellation that same day hbo
greenlighted instead another game of
thrones prequel direct to sirius that's
co-created by george r martin and ryan
condole
kondo will be a co-show runner with
famous game of thrones director miguel
sapochnick who will also work on the
pilot and additional episodes in the
prequel series called house of the
dragons
house of the dragon will draw from
georgia or martin's novel fire and blood
which reveals more about the history of
the targaryens